Throughout Scream 2, we see a few glimpses
of the movie Stab! which is essentially
the in-universe version of Scream 1.
Each character’s Stab! counterpart is
played by a known actor from our
world, and in the case of Sidney,
that actress is Tori Spelling, which is
playing off of a joke from the original Scream.
– [Tatum] Hey, Sid, just think. If they make a
movie about you, who's gonna play you?
– I see you as a young Meg Ryan myself.
– Thanks Dewey, with my luck,
they'd cast Tori Spelling.
– It’s at one point suggested that the
new killer is trying to make an in
real life sequel to the happenings
in Woodsboro from the year before,
and Scream 2 consequently features many
scenes that call back to the original. To
learn the meaning behind the graffiti,
stick around to the end of this video.
– And I’ll be back when you guys start talking
about something a little
more Saved by the Bell ish.
(metal music)
– Welcome to Things You Missed. I am Zac Morris. As
I discussed last episode, Scream 1 was a satire on
horror movies, so naturally Scream 2 satirizes
sequels. In fact, it openly acknowledges that
they’re usually inferior to the original… so
what’s the deal here? Did they intentionally
make Scream 2 an inferior movie? In the movie
premiere scene, Maureen gets flack from her
fellow movie goers when she *loudly* encourages
the character on screen to use some common sense.
Scream 2 features previously intelligent
characters doing things that make you want to
*ahem* Scream at the television, like
splitting up with a killer in the vicinity,
backing up against a window and going back
to unmask someone when you should just run.
– [Randy] The way I see it,
someone’s out to make a sequel.
You know, cash in on all the movie murder hoopla.
– [Zac] …says Randy, as he enjoys his product
placement. Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
(mysterious music)
In the first Scream, I talked about how the
movie started by pulling a page from Alfred
Hitchcock’s Psycho by killing off it's poster girl.
This time, the poster features two more big stars,
Jada Pinkett and Sarah Michelle Gellar.
Jada’s character Maureen is the second to
die after her boyfriend, just like Casey,
and Sarah’s character Cici is third.
Also, speaking of pulling a page from
Psycho, the opening scene of Stab adds
a part where Casey goes into the shower.
The shot of the tap turning on is the same
shot from Psycho. The rest of the scene is
pretty accurate to what we saw in Scream,
including the conversation, which begs the
question: how would the creators of Stab
know what transpired that night unless… one
of the participants was actually still alive?
Scream 1 used Halloween as a template, a movie
that everybody knows and can understand how it’s
being satirized. But Scream 2 doesn’t really
offer an equivalent. However, Stab acts as
an in-universe stand-in for Scream 1, and we’ve
seen something similar in the Halloween franchise.
In Halloween III, we see that the original
Halloween is just a movie in that universe. Halloween III
is also a famously panned sequel, but other than
that, there aren’t really any other similarities.
Scream had become famous and there were already
movies in production trying to imitate it. So
the challenge was on for Scream 2 to try to be
the best imitator. While the first Scream made its
gimmick apparent by having the killers quiz Casey
on scary movies while being in a scary movie,
Scream 2 tells us that these movie fans are
about to be in a movie of their own
by using screen direction. ‘Stab Casey’
is seen running to the left towards a door,
and then we cut to Phil going
left through a door himself.
This link is the director’s way of telling
us that he’s about to be a victim too.
We hear the song Red Right Hand by
Nick Cave and the Bad Seeds twice
in this movie. In the first one it played
during the curfew lockup montage, and in 2,
we hear it right as Stab is beginning and
as the Delta Lambda Zeta party disperses,
perhaps another link to tell us that
the movie is leaking into reality.
There are a lot of instances where things in
Scream 2 fill the role for material from the first
one. For example, Sidney’s college mascot is the
Wildcats, a less specific version of the Panthers,
which was her high school mascot. It plays
into the idea that we have copycat killers,
just like how the initial 3 victims share a
name with the first three victims in Woodsboro.
Sidney once again gets unwanted attention from the
press because of her past. The scene where Cici
is attacked at her sorority home is just like the
scene of Sidney being attacked at her actual home.
And just like Scream 1, Ghostface pops out
from a closet by the stairs. I wonder
if the fact that he hides “under the stairs”
is a Wes Craven reference. Cici’s immediate
reaction is to then run up the stairs, just
like high school Sidney said she would.
– Some stupid killer stalking some
big breasted girl who can’t act
who’s always running up the stairs when
she should be going out the front door.
– The ice cream scene is the new video
store scene. In the video store scene,
Randy directly determines who one of the killers
is by accusing Billy, who fires back by asking…
– How do we know you’re not the killer?
– And Randy admits that if this were
a scary movie, he would, in fact,
be a prime suspect. This time, he correctly
identifies Mickey as one of the killers.
– The freaky Tarantino film student.
– But also concedes that he would likely
be a suspect on the same grounds.
– [Randy] But if he’s a suspect, so am I.
– Worth noting in this scene, he’s
also kind of on the right track
when it comes to the second killer. He
brings up Mrs. Voorhees as proof that
the killer could be a female. Like
Mrs. Voorhees from Friday the 13th,
the killer is the mom of another killer.
Randy’s other suspect is Gale Weathers.
– That’s what reporters do,
Dewey. They stage the news.
– He’s got the right idea, but he’s got the wrong
reporter. History repeats itself later in the
movie when Gale and Dewey team up, and Gale makes
an important discovery while they're hooking up. In the original it’s Neil
Prescott’s car, in the sequel it’s Mickey’s
tapes. The killer is once again behind Randy.
– Look behind you.
– Dewey gets stabbed in the back again. Gale blocks
the door to the recording studio so that
Ghostface can only reach in and flail.
It’s like Sidney in her room. Mickey reveals
himself as the killer using a familiar line.
– Surprise Sidney!
– …just like Stu did during the
last 20 minutes of Scream.
– Surprise Sidney!
– At the end, Sidney buries one into
Mrs. Loomis’s forehead just like
she had to her son, and it all ends with
Cotton foreshadowing the next Stab film.
– [Cotton] I’ll tell you one thing.
It will make a hell of a movie.
– But there is one easter egg that even I wouldn’t
have found if not for this
retrospective documentary.
(cinematic impact)
(dark music)
I’m sure you noticed the way Ghostface
wipes off the knife in Scream 2. It’s
a signature move established by Stu in the
first movie. I wanted to bring it up though,
because in my video on the first film,
I tried to, as I do, figure out what
the subtext might be behind this. However,
in the 2011 retrospective Still Screaming,
Dane Farwell, the stunt actor in that
scene offers a simpler explanation.
– It’s a direct cut to me running
through the hall with a clean knife.
Wes just thought for two seconds and said,
“We’ll wipe the knife off on camera.”
– Another thing I talked about in my first
video was relevant cameo appearances,
and those seem to have been given
special attention here in 1997.
Director of Photography Peter Deming plays the
‘Popcorn Boy’. Screenwriter Kevin Williamson
is the interviewer on “Current Edition”.
I never would have noticed this on my own,
but Matthew Lillard, who plays Stu in Scream,
used 2% of his power to make a background cameo
at the party scene, which thankfully for me,
he brought up in the retrospective, otherwise
I never would have known it was him.
– One day I was just hanging out and they were
like ‘come walk in the back of the party scene’.
– And director Wes Craven makes another appearance,
this time as a doctor at the hospital scene. That
one I actually found out about from a fan site,
which is coincidentally also called “Still
Screaming.” The best cameo though is this one,
from Lev Shrieber’s dog. What a boy. There are a
bunch of other cameos, but on Things You Missed,
I’m only interested in ones that have some kind
of significance or something to do with the movie.
After a film class discussion on
sequels and imitators of movie killers,
Gale brushes off the idea of
audience safety being important.
– Are you kidding me? It’d
be stupid to pull this movie.
All this free press they’re gonna
have huge numbers this weekend.
–  [Zac] You either die a hero, or live long
enough to see yourself become the villain.
Despite this movie’s concept:
being a take-off of horror sequels,
we aren’t bombarded with movie references like
we were in Scream. Instead, there’s another
theme that the finale centers itself around:
theatre. Sidney is a theatre major and has a
prominent role in the production of Agamemnon,
which is advertised all over the campus.
– [Gus] Cassandra is one of the great tragic
visionaries of literature. She saw it all coming.
The wars, the murder, the madness. She knew she
was cursed. It was her fate and she embraced it.
– This might be a comparison between two unlikely
subjects to be paired, horror movie final girls
and greek mythology. One of the things that
audiences tend to find ridiculous about
sequels is the fact that the same characters
get themselves into trouble again. It always
seems like a huge coincidence that only exists to
extend the franchise. That’s why in a lot of long
running franchises, there’s some kind of curse
that keeps the killer coming back again and again.
The character Sidney plays in Agamemnon is
Cassandra, who is literally cursed by the
Greek God Apollo. In the case of Scream,
it’s obviously not like a magic curse,
but rather that Sidney is cursed by the publicity
of the horrible things that have happened to her.
I do think it’s significant that their
whole culture on campus revolves around
these sororities, or as they are sometimes called,
Greek Life. In the car crash scene, there’s some
graffiti of the Greek letters representing the
sorority where the party took place earlier, Delta
Lambda Zeta, along with text in English that says
“stab this”. But the Greek letters are crossed
out in red, and this is the scene where their
pledge, Hallie, gets herself crossed off by Mickey.
The movie’s climax takes place on the
stage where the “Fall of Troy” set is still
up. This is where Ghostface attacks
her on more than one occasion. The
Greek vs. the Trojan so to speak. At the
end she actually uses her Greek letters,
given to her by her boyfriend to protect her,
to attack Mickey, and ultimately get away.
The play that she’s in is Agamemnon,
which like Stab, is the first chapter of a
trilogy. Scream
was a trilogy from 2000-2011.
(rock music)
– [Mickey] Empire Strikes Back. It was a
better story. Improved effects.
– [Randy] Not a sequel, part of
a trilogy, completely planned.
– In Scream, I think I pointed out like
20 different Nightmare on Elm Street references,
but Scream 2 seems to just have one, when Cotton
is arrested by Sidney’s bodyguards in the library
we see a book called Our Dreaming Mind, which
deals with the science of sleep and dreams,
much like how Nancy visits a sleep disorder
clinic to try fix her Freddy Fr--
(BEEP)
(laughing) to try to fix her Freddy Freeman problem...
...to try to fix her Freddy Krueger problem.
For a minute, I thought this was Freddy’s
iconic sweater in Sid’s dorm room,
but when I actually compared them, I
realized they’re not the same. I had
the same thing happen in Sid’s room
when I analyzed the first Scream,
I thought this was Chucky’s sweater, but
eventually realized the colors don’t match.
Scream 2 has a girl that looks kind of like
Chucky, but again, the colors don’t match.
As I did for the first movie, I want
to wrap up by talking about some of
the evidence about who the killers are,
some of which you might have missed.
(cinematic impact)
(spooky dance music)
First up we’ve got Cici’s sorority house, where we
can confirm that there are once again, two killers
because you can still hear one Ghostface talking
on the phone as the other sneaks through the front
door in the background. During certain chase scenes, we
hear Ghostface grunting. Sometimes it sounds male…
(male grunting sounds)
– … and at other times, the sound is female.
(female grunting sounds)
– But when speaking on the phone, we can’t make this
determination because of the voice changer. When
Sidney gets a Ghostface call from Debra Salt aka
Mrs. Loomis at the sorority house, she hears this…
– [Caller] Hello Sidney. Remember me?
– …suggesting that it’s someone from Sidney’s
past, like her late ex-boyfriend’s mom.
And from a filmmaking standpoint, when you make a
sequel, you have to include enough information so
that even audiences who haven’t seen the first one
can keep up. We only see two scenes from Stab,
the opening and this scene, which reminds
us that Billy’s Mom left him and his Dad.
They only reason to cut away from the scene we’re
in and show that part is if that information
is going to somehow be important. Like if
Billy’s Mom were to, for example, come back.
Debra also suspiciously manages
to get to the scene of the crime
at the sorority house where Cici was
attacked and at the film school where
Dewey was attacked before anyone else.
Maybe because she was already there.
But the strongest evidence is actually the
evidence for Mickey being guilty. In class,
he argues for the idea that sequels can
be better than the original. Of course
he would say that. The Windsor murders
are his sequel to the Woodsboro murders.
– [Sidney] You know, I knew
this was coming? I knew
this wasn’t over?
– [Mickey] You are not alone Sid.
– Yeah, he would know that this was coming
because he was responsible. The most
damning evidence though is the fact that he
always has his video camera. When Dewey and
Gale go to study their tapes, they see
each of the crime scenes was recorded
from Ghostface’s point of view. The only
issue is that he isn’t the one projecting
these tapes. He must have given them to Mrs.
Loomis at some point, because he was planning
on getting caught so he could use the trial
to try to blame the movies for his actions.
OK, I take back what I said. The
most damning evidence against Mickey
is the fact that we can see him right here
through the eyeholes of the Ghostface mask.
Scream 2 was famously rewritten during production
because the ending leaked on the internet,
so the fact that we have all these setups
is kind of impressive. We’re mostly all in
agreement that Scream 1 is superior, and I
think the very idea that the sequel’s villain
could just be switched like that is kind of a
testament to it being a weaker story. However,
with all of that being said, I guess Cotton was going
to be one of the villains originally? And I’m
sort of glad that didn’t happen because his
redemption at the end is one of the best parts,
and it sets us up for Scream 3. Which I’ll
be covering next time on Things You Missed.
Check out my Scream playlist on the left for that,
and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell and make
sure you select all notifications. I’ll see
you in the next one, assuming we both survive.
(spooky dance music)